[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo nos
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
el 24 de febrero marcó un antes y un
después la invasión rusa Ucrania desató
uno de los más grandes y rápidos
desplazamientos de personas desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en los primeros
días de la ofensiva más de 200.000
ucranianos cruzaron las fronteras en
busca de seguridad y rápidamente ese
número creció hasta hoy cuando se
cuentan más de 8 millones de refugiados
en países europeos las estimaciones de
la agencia de la ONU para los refugiados
se ubican a Rusia como el primer país
receptor luego está Polonia un país que
fue clave en la acogida inicial de los
que huyeron de la guerra en Alemania
República Checa Italia España y Reino
Unido se refugia a otro gran número de
ucranianos
un año después del Éxodo masivo Qué ha
pasado con los refugiados ucranianos un
buen número se instaló en países vecinos
pero otros cruzaron miles de kilómetros
incluso hubo algunos que esperaron por
un permiso de entrada en la frontera sur
de Estados Unidos veamos a continuación
algunos de sus testimonios
el rostro ensangrentado de Elena courilo
captado el 24 de febrero de 2022
presagiaba El horror de la guerra un
primer misil impactó a 500 metros de su
vivienda cerca de harky el segundo la
destruyó por completo un año después
esta profesora es uno de los millones de
refugiados ucranianos en el mundo
resultó ser que mi foto fue la primera
en ser considerada como símbolo de esta
guerra en Ucrania
esto por supuesto es una carga muy
pesada
en Rusia no creían que era yo decían que
era actriz que fue una explosión de gas
que era que mi sangre no era sangre
ahora vive en Polonia anhela regresar a
Ucrania y espera abrir una fundación
para ayudar a los niños que quedaron
huérfanos por la guerra
en Reino Unido esta mujer y su pequeña
hija buscan un nuevo comienzo tras
perder a su familia en un bombardeo
soldados rusos en las mantuvieron
cautivas en el sótano de una escuela
meses después encontraron Un refugio en
un pequeño pueblo inglés pero esta madre
asegura que las secuelas no son fáciles
de llevar
Me estoy acostumbrando un poco entiendo
que todavía no hay otra salida así que
me estoy acostumbrando pero todos los
días pienso en que quiero irme a casa
cuando termine la guerra su casa es
Ucrania y su vida estaba en Cherry Hill
Irina camina por las calles de Viena
antes transitada por irpín en Ucrania
pero ahora este es su lugar seguro se
refugió junto a su familia a kilómetros
de lo que conocía sus hijos intentan
integrarse y el yugo les ayuda a
acercarse a su nueva vida Valery el
padre de esta familia viajó con ellos
muchos hombres no pudieron hacerlo
porque fueron llamados a combate
los que quieren ir a la guerra están
motivados yo no puedo hacerlo Ni
siquiera puedo matar a un insecto no
tengo el reflejo de tomar un arma de ir
a matar gente Todos Somos humanos
en casa Irina intenta mantener las
tradiciones y se niega a dejarlas porque
sueñan con el fin de la guerra y con el
momento en el que puedan regresar para
ayudar a reconstruir lo que queda de su
país
la guerra no solo tuvo efectos para la
población ucraniana ante la
incertidumbre de un nuevo conflicto
algunos rusos también se fueron de su
país un número importante de personas
decidió emigrar a Argentina y en la
actualidad más de 9000 rusos están en el
país nuestro corresponsal en Buenos
Aires natalio cosoy nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
Amalia tiene todo listo para el
nacimiento de su hija que puede ocurrir
en cualquier momento junto con su marido
Eugenia vivían en San Petersburgo y
llegaron a Argentina en enero de 2023
las consecuencias de la invasión rusa
Ucrania los convencieron de irse de su
país sobre todo cuando se volvió una
posibilidad que hugen y fuera llamado
para ir al frente
tenía miedo de dejarlo salir
ellos son parte de un creciente número
de ciudadanos rusos que están arribando
Argentina según datos de la dirección
Nacional de migraciones en enero de 2023
llegaron cuatro veces más que en el
mismo mes de 2022 de hecho
[Música]
esto en los vuelos hay más personas
tener un hijo argentino ayuda con los
trámites de residencia Julia Pepe la
lleva llegó mucho antes Hace seis años
en Argentina tuvo sus dos hijos es
influencer ayuda a los rusos que quieren
vivir en el país y creó una guía sobre
Argentina que vende en línea desde que
comenzó la guerra crecieron muchísimo
las consultas que le llegan a sus redes
sociales los rusos ven en Argentina un
buen destino para emigrar acá a rusos
pueden entrar Para 90 días y después
hacer residencia por acá por eso hay
muchos rusos además por supuesto de
querer alejarse de un país en guerra
como Amalia y Eugenia ellos hicieron
este viaje dicen para darle un futuro
mejor a su hija
para nosotros dos es importante que
nuestra hija crezca en una sociedad
saludable
y mientras amaia y esperan el nacimiento
de su hija siguen llegando Argentina
numerosos ciudadanos rusos alejándose
del conflicto y de un país que ya no es
para ellos un lugar adecuado para vivir
meses después de abandonar Ucrania por
la guerra un 65% de los refugiados dice
que prefiere permanecer en el país que
los acoge hasta que inmigrantes de
France 24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrante cf24 sigan con más información
en France 24 y 24 punto com
[Música]